do you know that it's the memo like  maybe I just don't want anyone maybe no  one's like living up to the plate okay  so so I expected a lot okay well I just  think of this there's one of you and  there's the whole population of men  so you know what it is I'm sorry to say  but the UK is mid no but I think it's  also social media I think people  nowadays they meet someone and then they  you know he can be  um if you're into men like he can be you  know the whole package but because of  Socials you're like oh but he's but he's  but he's but so I feel like a lot of  people struggle to actually like build  something with someone because they're  always thinking there might be something  better